have you ever wondered if you watched
the snow long enough
what stories it might tell
there is someone who has done it
his name
is billy barr i spell it small b-i-l-l-y
small b-a-r-r
some people call him the snow guardian
he lives in a cabin out in the woods
picture this
it's a snowy day it's dark and cold and
you make a fire and you're sitting by
the fire and you're reading with a cup
of tea and it goes on for nine months
billy lives alone in this house he
helped build
here he grows his garden
has an impressive hat collection
loves cricket
and dreams of bollywood
every couple of weeks he skis back into
the nearest town for supplies
he's been doing this for more than 40
winters
[Music]
but billy does a little more than just
read and drink tea
for those 40 winters billy has kept a
meticulous record of snow in his little
part of the world
okay like it said february 26 1978
10 and a half inches of snow that day
january 20th minus 11 and a half april
28 1980 i was 41.
in
1997 one half inch new snow a weasel was
roaming around inside the shack damn the
birds were back
[Music]
i lived in an 8 by 10 foot old shack
and had no electricity no water and i
had nothing and i was just there all day
the main thing i interacted with was the
weather and the animals
so i started recording things just
because it was something to do
[Music]
i had nothing to prove no goals no
anything
so actually a researcher at the lab
wanted to look at it and then once he
started looking at it scientifically
then all of a sudden like these decades
worth of data were being used for more
than my own curiosity
[Music]
billy has done this every day twice a
day all winter long
[Music]
i'd keep going until the snow was gone
if it snowed i would record that no
matter when
the trend i see is that we're getting a
permanent snowpack later and we get to
bare ground sooner
we'll have years where there was a lot
of snow on the ground
and then we lost no sooner than years it
had a lot less snow just because it's a
lot warmer now
in a normal winter you'd expect to have
four to five record high temperatures
last year billy recorded 36. not only is
it a lot warmer we're getting a lot of
dust blowing in as soon as you get dust
on the snow it melts like that you're
talking about the the snow pack the
water supply for most of the southwest
i'm not real hopeful
just because
i don't know how you reverse something
like that
[Music]
as we leave colorado behind billy
imparts one last bit of advice
it's like anything else
you know i learned to ski to get around
i learned how to ski better so i
wouldn't fall down all the time
over a period of time i kind of learned
how to survive in this environment
actually learning to fall was probably
the most important thing
you're going to fall sick
a lot easier falling on your butt than
on your face
[Music]
you